Dude, what is with the Easy Buttons?
I thought you were gonna get, like, the receptionist
bell, so we could do the dings like from the
sins videos.
I looked man.
I don't know where to find those things.
I don't know what store sells those.
We can't debate movies and keep score using
an easy button.
That's beyond lame.
People will think we're stupid.
Well this is the best I could do, okay, so
do you wanna do it, or complain about it?
Okay.
Okay, so let's talk about The Hobbit.
Let's talk about the Hobbit.
The Hobbit sucks!
Why does The Hobbit suck?
The Hobbit sucks because of all the goofy
sh*t.
Goofy sh*t?
The snot, the body noises, the wacky f*cking
brown wizard.
This movie is silly as f*ck.
Okay, I will grant you that there are some
moments in the movie that are a little bit
silly.
"That was easy."
Point for me.
Okay.
My turn.
The Gollum scene.
Let's hear you say something bad about the
Gollum scene.
Even an idiot like you has to know how awesome
that scene was.
Let's hear you say it was bad.
I wanna hear it.
Come on.
I can't argue that.
I can't.
"That was easy."
Exactly.
Thank you.
You happy now?
Yeah, I'm happy now.
The dishes song.
The dishes song is in the book!
No, no.
No movie that takes a tiny ass book and splits
it out into three movies and then fills it
with all kinds of filler sh*t that wasn't
actually there?
That movie doesn't get to claim 'It was in
the book' when I criticize.
That movie has left the book behind a long
time ago.
Another problem with the dishes song is this.
I cannot believe that didn't break.
Exactly!
There's no way those dwarfs could have done
that without breaking all the dishes.
"That was easy."
It's dwarves.
What?
It's dwarves, not dorfs.
"That was easy."
That's not even a point about the movie.
I don't care.
I score a point every time you're a moron.
Now let's talk about the action, because it
was awesome.
No it isn't!
The action is kid-friendly.
It's stupid.
It's like a dumbed-down version of what Middle
Earth action ought to be.
And that's stupid.
"That was easy."
You can't just score a point without any debate.
Yes I can.
No you can't.
And I just did.
What are you gonna do about it?
I guess I'm gonna sit here and--
Alright the other problem is the bloat.
The what?
The bloat.
The bloat?
This movie has so much unnecessary scenery,
this movie has so many unnecessary characters.
It's ridiculous.
To prove my point, I brought somebody else
to help us, to discuss it.
You brought somebody else?
Geez, dude you know I freakin' hate this guy.
Why do you have to bring this guy?
We don't need him to debate movies.
He doesn't add anything.
Exactly!
Tell me this isn't exactly how you felt when
Frodo showed up and did nothing.
Elrond and Galadriel, the masters of boredom,
had a 15 minute conference with Gandalf.
Tell me this isn't exactly how you felt when
the mother f*cker shows up on a sled drawn
by rabbits!
If I agree with you will you tell him to go?
Yeah.
Get rid of him?
Alright the rabbits are stupid.
The rabbits are dumb.
"That was easy."
Alright, so get rid of him.
He's not that bad, really.
I mean, he's a little slow, but--
We made a deal.
He sure is friendly.
We made a deal, you said you were gonna get
rid of him.
We did.
But have you ever tried getting rid of this
guy?
It's next to impossible.
Then why did you even invite him over in the
first place.
Can you at least tell him to stop staring
at me like that.
Hey!
You're bothering him!
Can I come in?
Hello?